report in clark county showing the test
positivity is still growing but at a
much slower pace it's sitting at 38.2
percent up from 38 percent yesterday
over the past few months the omicron
variant has helped push it far above the
8 percent goal set by state health
leaders that high rate also means we're
on the state's watch list for elevated
transmission risk
all 50 states in fact reporting a high
level of covet transmission this as a
new study from the cdc is gaining
traction it compares protection from
covid based on prior infection or
vaccination and it found people who were
both vaccinated and had survived covet
had the most protection
unvaccinated people with a past
infection were close second experts
stress it is still much safer to get
vaccinated and wear the most protective
mask high filtration masks including n95
respirators can 95 and kf-94
provide better protection than cloth
masks or even surgical masks
also those free n95 masks promised by
the white house they're now available at
a number of locations here in southern
nevada including costco cvs walgreens
walmart and even albertsons you can find
all the locations on our website at
eightnewsnow.com or just point your cell
phone camera at the qr code on your
screen it'll take you to our website for
that list and other helpful resources